today we're gonna learn how to survive
everything
we're gonna be immortal and you two
watching by the end of this video we're
gonna be prepared for anything coming
our way are you telling me we're gonna
be able to survive cancel culture
and that's impossible get out of here
no we will do that as well we will cover
it yeah that's good I'll write that to
the list I believe
fantastic wonderful I'm always annoyed
by this I don't know why it always
annoys me when someone goes do you know
how to baby pee I'm like no I don't why
it's not gonna happen but now I feel
like I need to know I just want to knock
them all out so I don't have to think
about it ever again and we're done this
actually started with me doing that too
much yeah because there was a we were
watching this uh K drama and the boy was
drowning in the frozen lake and I was
like well
I know how to survive that I bet you
don't know how to survive
this uh
well actually how to survive falling
through the ice okay I got this tutorial
here first of all what would you do Ken
if you were in ice you got a short time
to survive here you gotta do like they
do in the movies and you guys you gotta
push yourself under the ice and start
swimming you know towards the edge and
like start banging on it and then it
starts getting intense and then you pull
your gun out and start blasting holes in
it and then you break the surface yeah
and the ice will be stiffer there and
you like start crawling out and you
equal your body away to cross and slide
that's true that's straight you gotta
equal your body weight but okay here's
the thing with this one that annoys me
it's like oh you need a pickaxe to like
pull yourself out of course yeah I'm not
gonna have that otherwise I'm not
watching this video in my dear drowning
in ice you pull out your iPhone to be
like how to survive
I need to I need a pickaxe I don't have
that you're like oh thank God I'm like a
number one Minecraft bro when you pull
your trusty pickaxe out you always carry
with you I have a pickaxe why why do
they think of that like what is this of
course I'm gonna use my pickaxe if I
have it so dumb I hate that this is why
I hate it this is this weird like if you
knew how to survive a nice you would
bring that with you and you don't need
to watch this video true you would have
already seen the video you would know
you would know I thought I came here to
learn something okay no it's just me
complaining but it but but but here's
what reminds me I fail than that if the
ice is cracking what do you do
underneath you cracking how many yeah
you got a starfish that mug you know you
got to spread it you got a starfish
that's right even teach you that in
Minnesota
Mississippi oh we know all about
starfishes don't worry about that
chocolate starfishes are Delicacies all
right I think we know how to not how to
survive a frozen ice yeah we did it we
survived yeah all right next up elevator
you're not gonna tell me that you gotta
jump right before he hits the bottom or
something all right well here we go
let's check it out what would you do
jump a brace yourself embrace yourself
lie flat on the floor I'll lay on the
floor starfish gang starfish
just to see how it feels I I feel like
I'm probably gonna die anyway and it
probably feels cool to jump yeah you
chose jump you're probably dead
just the right moment as the elevator's
hitting floor you slow down the speed of
your fall and that gives you a soft
Landing but chances that you could make
it work are slim so there is a chance
have you seen this yeah yeah
you were designed to survive characters
yeah apparently it's about car crashes
you have to have like 12 nipples
all right so now we know how to also
survive a car crash I feel like this
applies for the elevator too like if you
look like this and you're in an elevator
and it's crashing down you don't even
need to lay down you're good you can
survive everything if you look like this
the friend zone falling out of a plane
all right we got elevator we got ice
what's next skin we gotta get attacked
by the animal next right bears bear Soul
has hit me off so much too because it's
like oh uh okay so tell me what you need
to do what you need to do Ken tell me
how do you survive well you just gotta
he's gonna play dead it's what they say
right they say play dead and then
they're like oh but not if it's this
bear because then they'll eat you we'll
put my trusty Scout book here and figure
out what kind of bear this is Google it
real quick this is the kind of video
where they tell you hey use bear spray
no sh I'm gonna use bear spray if I have
it on me the point is to what it's like
all right Batman you know you just fell
in the ice you got your your bat pick
the Bear's attacking you got your your
bat bear spray where you got your
bazooka and shoot the bear if you
and then
oh yeah there we go spray him cool
awesome couldn't I figure that one out
right for about two seconds imagine
having bearish spray not using it
because you're too dumb to realize you
need to use it like come on I don't even
know if I'd be able to spray a bear if
it's that close to me those things are
huge you'd be scared of spraying so
you're saying you would die you would
spray yourself I mean I feel like this
is uh you don't have a lot of room for
error here so there's a lot of you got
to be pretty clutch to pull this off oh
the bear's coming better get my bear
spray and wait until he's you know yeah
but that's when you're a Tomatoes hyper
Instinct kicks in here like
that yeah yeah yeah you don't mess that
up all right so what do you need to do
as fast as possible all right thanks but
run from the video spray yes what should
you do then yes step four choose your
survival strategy okay finally if you
end up on a date with a black bear you
might be relatively safe but don't ruin
the moment by climbing up a tree
blackberries are much better climbers
than you are oh okay don't climb tree
got it but they're better climbing on
this I feel like that's a challenge have
you ever tried a commentary yeah of
course not easy like unless there's like
a low limb you can grab and pull
yourself up like like bear hugging a
tree and trying to climb it that's
that's a good point and don't try to
play dead black bears don't fall for
that what it is super bear you can't
climb tree you can't play dead what are
you gonna do instead hit the bear with a
stick throw dude no I'm not gonna hit
that's mean I'm gonna challenge him
you're gonna throw down the gauntlet and
be like you want some of this Bear show
him who's boss oh okay all right with
Grizzlies it's different
he'll catch you and eat you before you
know it oh great best bet is to fall in
the fetal position and protect your head
neck and stomach okay okay I got it Ken
black bear Chad brown bear bear right
okay that makes sense I feel I feel like
my brain will purposely mess me up when
I'm in this I it'll just be like was it
black was it brown do antagonize the
brown bear or the black bear what was it
think of a rocky like ah come at me it
smells you
okay black Chad Brown beta got it okay
all right what's next on the survival
list Ken what do you what would you want
to know what else you got on the list
well one thing that I I feel like I
should know because in in UK there is a
lot of like wetlands and swamps and
bombs and I thought he was about to say
cows
shut up shut up that's actually good
I'll write that down in case we need to
look it up
how to escape quicksane oh here you
don't have to because you won't actually
die in it what like it just does it work
like you think it does in the movies and
everything like you're just kind of
sinking to swim out of it it's basically
impossible to die and the way depicted
in movies because quicksand is denser
than the human body oh so it sinks while
you float up eventually okay the answer
is inconclusive if you ask me okay but
uh yeah so Ken if you're uh sunken into
quicksand just say hey it's fine I won't
die don't worry guys I'll get out in a
minute I may lose my shoes but I'll get
out of here don't worry here's what are
you supposed to do according to French
lady with bad audio
put the weight on one leg and then pull
all right we need some acronym or
something to so I remember it and when I
mean I need acronyms the wolf
wiggle your foot yeah wait wait on one
foot yeah you gotta whoop it you gotta
move it if you're in the quick stage you
gotta move face they should have said
you tie the rope to your pickaxe that
you always have Minecraft bro throw it
out there you pull yourself out do you
take off your DJI drone you make it Fly
really high you throw a last bit on top
of it and you pull yourself out you're
welcome thank you pull out your
quicksand spray and spray that mug and
you just it hardens up finale what do
you do well I think it's like as soon as
you when you when you walk outside and
you notice how the water is weirdly low
hop in your car and start booking it
because it's coming an early sign of an
impending tsunami is that the water
along the coast will recede yeah and
exposes the sea floor do not go to the
beach to investigate you'll only be
putting yourself at risk for when the
water surges back instead head in the
opposite direction yeah sure that dude
that's me right there
I just love that and go in the opposite
way of danger I'm like wow no way
so me for those of you don't know me and
Ken are baffled by the fact that people
die from cows 20 people die every year
how do you avoid a cow attack first you
get rid of it
I'm in my cancer culture here we go ah
yes always be honest the best defense is
always the truth this is terrible advice
off to a bad start don't try to cancel
others what do you mean no you need to
throw everyone under the bus
black yeah all right Ken now we know how
to survive anything and so do you
watching you're welcome smash like
subscribe check out Ken see you next
time
Edgar what are you doing you're browsing
the internet unprotected oh my God
bro how many times I gotta tell you you
gotta download nordvpn Wi-Fi right with
nordvpn all your internet data stays
safe behind the wall of Next Generation
encryption Next Generation
you will be the last generation sorry
what about logs there's a straight no
logs policy they don't track collect
anything
you will be safe
Don't Be Afraid child get access to the
actual World Wide Web hundreds of
streaming services worldwide bam I'm in
Japan watching anime boom I'm in India
watching
watching everything except lasagna
you can use on multiple devices as well
you can use it on your phone on your
computer it's easy as a one
clickety-clack and they let you connect
up to six devices Edgar's gone tired now
all right time to wrap up if you go to
nordvpn.com PewDiePie with the link in
the description you get a huge bonus so
take advantage of that because you also
get for additional months for free so
use the link in the description while
you sign up to take advantage for me a
VPN is a must when I'm doing banking on
another Wi-Fi network or if I want to
watch shows from different countries
it's always there and it's super easy to
use so I recommend it nordvpn.com
PewDiePie use the link thank you for
sponsoring this video let's get on with
it